hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to there's
this idea going around that slapstick is
a lesser form of humor well to them I
say I'll slapstick focuses on the most
important rule of comedy that all comedy
in one way or another is based on misery
whether it be mocking something others
hold dear or crushing another in a
perfectly time manner humor is that
defense mechanism that acknowledges that
pain is just another part of life and
nowhere DC pain exploited more
hilariously than in Tom and Jerry
this chem mouse duo has had both kids
and adults laughing for years through no
real dialogue no real stories just
excuses to crush burn and maim each
other as much as physically possible now
what these shorts came out cartoons
hurting each other wasn't anything new
lots of cartoon shorts including Disney
and especially Warner Brothers seem to
have this dig down pretty well but if
there was already two major companies
doing it so well how come Tom and Jerry
rose to be the pinnacle slapstick duo's
well maybe one of the main reasons was
there was rarely any talking I mean
there was an occasional line from one or
two other characters the Talmud jury
themselves usually kept quiet perhaps
allowing less time to devote to
motivation and instead more time to
devote to the physical humor Warner
Brothers is great but half their comedy
was the words they would say to one
another in between the violence and that
worked wonderful for them but here they
take a few moments to set up the
scenario and then it's nothing but
hardcore pain the rest of the way giving
many audiences exactly what they wanted
on top of that despite the fact that
they couldn't speak they actually did
form very solid personalities jerry is
playful innocent and often looking to
just have fun or even just survive even
if he can have a little too much fun
surviving Tom being a cat of course sees
him either as a meal or as an
interference
whatever the setup he's always the one
who starts the fight which makes it very
easy to laugh when he gets his
comeuppance but that's not the only
reason to feel like he deserves it he's
cocky he's egotistical he's prone to
anger he's stubborn he's all the things
that make a great foil but never to the
point where he's unlikable he still has
that goofy playfulness that Jerry has
too which is why in the few instances
where they do come together it's not
entirely unbelievable but let's get down
to the reason why people really love Tom
and Jerry their lust for blood william
hanna and joseph barbera knew how to
animate great slapstick it makes sense
in animation seeing how so much of the
humor relies on timing and here you can
literally control each frame to the
tiniest detail giving you complete power
over your delivery and that's exactly
what they do they know exactly how fast
how hard and how painful every
of torture should be but it's one thing
to say they're good at it
exactly how are they good at it why does
the slapstick work so much better here
than a dozen other cartoons well because
again they understood that anything that
can emphasize the amount of pain a
character is in usually the funnier the
joke will be compare town and jury to
say this scene from an episode of Tiny
Toons now Tiny Toons most of the time
henkaa slapstick - but sometimes they
got a director or a team of animators
that didn't do it as well as an amour
bereted of course the idea of cartoons
is to exaggerate the possible turning it
into the impossible but in order for it
to be funny you have to know what to
exaggerate like watch this bit this
scene doesn't work as well because the
character is too stretchy and too
flexible it doesn't look like they're
getting hurt that bad because it doesn't
look solid enough now watch when Tom
gets hurt
this works so much better because even
though he's being distorted he still
feels solid in the area that they do
manipulate complements the weight of the
item that's causing the damage it's like
when you have a jar of play-doh
yeah it's stretchy and not too hard but
when you smash your fits down on it it
leaves an imprint so you can tell it's
still solid and the same can be said
here the objects usually leave an
imprint on top now if I was to smash my
fist down on the play-doh and it was to
stretch all over the place that would be
too distracting and thus we couldn't
connect with what we were seeing as well
the animators of Tom and Jerry knew that
the more you feel how solid they are the
more you feel the pain the same could be
said for the sounds that make in the
early days when they were still trying
to find their niche Tom and Jerry
especially Tom looked much more like
real-life animals and even sounded more
like real-life families now that's not
as funny because it's not as relatable
the only thing you think about when you
hear that sound is a real-life cat
getting hurt what sick would enjoy
that but when you add a human yell to it
suddenly it's more funny and yes every
single one of them is done by William
Hann
so why is this Hill funnier than actual
cat yo well on top of the surrealist
factor the idea of hearing a man's voice
come out of an animal's mouth as people
we understand a human being being heard
more than we do an animal animals don't
communicate with us the same way we
communicate with each other so naturally
we'll be able to find the humor easier
with something that acts more human
despite the fact that they look like an
animal that's another reason you almost
never see them on all fours the more
they made it look like animals acting
like people and not animals acting like
animals the more likely they were to get
allow they knew just want to have them
use their voices to and they were never
overplayed like some pieces of cat
burger that I know they were just used
at the appropriate time when the scene
needed something particularly silly to
up the humor Hey look this one
especially gets me just for the surreal
missile oh why the deeper voice why that
major echo why even those exact words I
don't know it's just so strange you have
to laugh at it but again if they use the
voices too much it would have gotten old
and it seemed like that wouldn't be
nearly as funny so they had to use them
sparingly the expressions are also
something hanna-barbera got down
perfectly the more content and
comfortable a character can be in their
environment the more funny it'll be when
it comes crackling down that's why so
often you'll see Tom give this mocking
grin when he thinks he's won the more
happy he is the harder the blow will be
that knocks him out of his bliss even a
simple questioning expression can work
as long as the character looks genuinely
confused
adding to the idea that the more the
character thinks he's connected to
what's really going on the funnier it
will be when reality comes smashing him
in the face
and the longer they keep it the more it
will build up how painful the payoff is
going to be in fact with that said half
the time you don't even need to see the
expression all the way through we never
see Tom hit the ground in this scene but
the idea that he would keep this face
all the way to the bottom just makes the
moment all the more hilarious they
practically headed down to mathematical
perfection so it Tom and Jerry were so
good at what they did how come they're
not as popular now as they were back
then I mean granted there's still big
names but you don't see them around as
much as you do Mickey Mouse or Bugs
Bunny I think part of that is that a lot
of people just didn't know what to do
with them after the animated movie
shorts died some tried live legendary
animator Chuck Jones gave his spin on
the classic duo but they were a bit too
friendly and oftentimes the animation
just wasn't on par with the original but
with that said it's not awful take this
scene where a Magic Mouse fairy comes
down and gives Jerry a magic potion in
order to help him defeat Tom
any series that has a scene like that
has some understanding of what may
tomandjerry work but aside from that we
had a lot of adaptations that seem to
aim toward much younger kids than it did
both kids and adults and even today that
still seems to be the lane trying to put
these two characters that obviously
belong in simplistic shorts into
dialogue heavy stories that rarely have
anything to do with what made them so
popular to begin with so whether or not
an outlet will open up for Tom and Jerry
to really shine again is unknown but
what is known is that when Tom and Jerry
got it right they got it right with a
perfect combination of animation timing
sound effects and a clearer
understanding of why physical humor will
never die as a comedic art this is why
they'll not as popular as they used to
be their names will not be forgotten
anytime soon they didn't break any
barriers or change the way animation is
done they just did what they did so well
and that was simply being funny and as
long as we keep orphan girls with
Indiana Jones fathers and ice cream cart
rapist out of the picture I can assure
you that Tom and Jerry will still be
relevant names for years to come
I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy remember it
so you don't have to
Oh
HIDA walker here and holy i mean
holy I'm of course talking about
the IndieGoGo thing that we did to raise
50 thousand to get our shows going or
other shows that this pop-culture and
nostalgia show this game shows on like
games who wanted to go and even with
still several days left we hit our goal
I mean like we hit 50 thousand we were a
Jew at 55 as I'm making this video and
holy everyone always says like oh
yeah yeah you'll make it come on your
big name stuff like that but you really
don't know there's a lot of things that
people assure you are gonna happen and
they don't so for something like this to
really come through for you guys to come
through we're gonna do our damage to
come through ourselves because this is
really really awesome and we really
couldn't be more thankful to you guys so
bottom of our hearts thank you so much
we're in the stretch goals now we're
into that territory and I'm just so here
real fast to tell you what the stretch
goals are as well as what the money that
we have now is going to is pretty much
the stuff we said before we're going to
use it to get the set put together for
the for the Nostalgia pop-culture show
you know to get the contestants going
and prizes going and we're updating all
our equipment we're updating new cameras
uh
the cameras we work with that the nice
but we won't go on to like the SDI stuff
which is going to look a lot more
professional it's going to be easy to
work with an editing live a new editing
equipment that's coming you know new
lighting all this stuff is coming to
make these productions and these shows
look even better than they are now so
all that is coming the stretch goals if
we hit a 65 pretty much we're going to
be going into the the comic book show
next we want to a comic show that's not
just a review show but sort of
everything comics we want to sort of
like this comic variety show that just
served welcomes and celebrates and rips
apart does everything comics pretty much
because this culture is just so grand
right now with the movies going and
just comics are just huge so we really
want to do something that really has fun
with that celebrate then talks about
that just all sorts of fun stuff and if
we hit a 75 K we're gonna go right into
the video game show we're gonna go into
having those episodes ready and set to
go we're gonna try and do new stuff with
that that you don't usually see video
game game shops are you know what I mean
but yeah cuz you if people should be
rewarded for their lazy asses sitting
down and playing those video games like
me when I play so um yeah pretty much
this whole thing is just blow my mind
man it is so cool
we've gone from I mean at least me
personally not knowing if we reach that
goal to going to stretch goals and that
that's you guys that made that possible
so it's it's the coolest thing it's so
awesome that you guys care that much the
people that donated the certain amounts
and have the perks coming that they'll
definitely be coming and man just I
don't even have the words I know it's
cliche but I really don't have the words
it is so awesome guys a lot of cool
stuff that's coming and now it'll get to
you even faster
we're excited I hope you're excited
we're gonna do our best to come through
and get good stuff for you guys so I'll
see you later as of now I'm gonna watch
some Korra